foreign
comes from Clark in Los Angeles Clark
writes we have three thousand six
hundred dollars in our bank account but
my wife wants to join a six-week MLM
training course for ten thousand dollars
it's her way or the highway on this
she was approved for a five thousand
dollar credit card and she applied for a
two thousand dollar loan with our bank
the deposit on the course is three
thousand dollars which she would take
from our checking leaving us with 600
bucks in the bank then there's the
payment plan
she's already been doing MLM for four
years which we have made zero profit on
am I crazy to be mad about her on this
matter I need your help
Dave I'm actually mad for Clark
like it's frustrating
it's frustrating this is somebody who's
out of control
yeah
yeah it is it's out of control
and
the the
one of the most aggravating things about
people that get into mlms not everyone
but but but some people get in it they
take on this cult-like
thing to where if you're not in it then
you must be stupid
and if you don't understand what I'm
doing then you're an idiot because only
people that are smart do I mean all the
smart people do this stuff and if you
don't understand and they actually some
of the mlms really some of the
hierarchies within certain mlms will
push that mentality we caught Mary Kay
about 15 years ago I don't know if they
still do it or not they were telling
ladies to uh use their credit card to
buy the stuff and not tell their husband
they're telling them from the stage to
lie to their husband yikes and I'm like
man that's some bad medicine right there
ladies you guys are you guys are freaks
this is nutty that's total greed run
amok well that's looking in your
checking account
you're
yeah sixty four hundred dollars off like
everything you've mentioned says that um
the the this entire plan is stupid
okay it's out of control and the but
Juiced up with a wife that says uh I'm
doing this because this is my way even
though there's absolutely no track
record in four years that she's ever
made any money doing it and there's no
there's no way to get this money
they might get this two thousand dollar
loan but I mean the exposure to the
whole family over this deal yeah and
she's she's putting everyone's putting
aside Common Sense she's putting us at
good financial decisions her marriage
Fidelity aside her uh her husband's
wishes she's putting aside the good of
her own family
all for her to chase this greed and this
is greed
make no mistake oh yeah because this is
I'm going to do this and then I'm going
to be able to buy a yacht
I'm going to live the dream
as the MLM people say and so uh that
that is straight up greed and when you
and when you push everyone including
Common Sense Good Financial sense your
husband's Wishes the good of your family
aside for your selfish greed you are a
mess you're a hot mess lady yeah you're
messed up so now what does Clark do I
think you guys have got to see a
marriage counselor I I think
instantaneously because I I always tell
couples man you be real careful with
my way or the highway my way or the
highway because people choose a highway
that's exactly right and use that for
very very rare circumstances and um she
pulled it on an MLM training course
like that's like that's like that's a
pretty big waste of that set of
ammunitions like being in Vegas and they
you're playing Texas Hold'em and they
give you a two and a six and you're just
like I'm all in like that's a bold move
with this
um so Dave just to just because Clark's
the only one we got here right yeah
she's not a part of this conversation
well if he has outlined it correctly
they got serious issues there's no
question they got serious issues this
also feels like a power play and
sometimes there's power plays because
people have lost their mind they're just
they're jerks they're nuts they bought
into something that is a cult and they
can't see the forest of the trees
sometimes people smash the other side of
the teeter-totter because somebody else
in the marriage has been holding it down
for so long and so long and so long and
so long and so Clark If that's you if
you have completely wrapped this house
up in this is my way of the highway and
she finally says enough this is my way
of the highway
um then that's something you need to put
on the table you might have a reap what
you've shown there you go but
if not brother I'm sorry
um I would go see somebody this week and
if she won't go you need to go by
yourself because it looks like y'all are
heading in completely different
directions yeah this marriage does not
last absolutely not without help nope
this does not help does not last okay
because she's she's ready to burn the
place down
for a dream that has absolutely no
underpinning whatsoever
and um she's ready to burn your family
burn you burn the finances burn
everything burn the marriage all over a
training course for MLM does that not
sound like the dumbest thing you ever
heard in your life I'm getting ready to
end every part of my life that's
positive for that
that that let me tell you if you're in
an MLM and you're recommending that your
people downline do that you should have
your butt kicked up around your neck and
wear it like a collar you really should
have somebody talk to you you're hurting
people you're hurting people you are
manipulative unbelievable jerk and
you've got to stop that and you're the
reason that people hate mlms is people
like you that do that now actually no a
few human beings and mlms that are
reasonable human beings absolutely and
they don't think I'm going to hell
because I'm not in their MLM it's not a
cult you know they believe in their
products they believe in their products
and it's their method of selling it and
I'm not mad at them that's not the point
the point is that the something about
the MLM culture generates ever so often
a company or a hierarchy within a
company that promotes this kind of crap
well it goes back to what I think it
makes me think of like Blockbuster they
made their money when their customers
lost they made their money on late fees
and they needed their customer to fail
so that they could make their money not
the other way around if you're teaching
people I lie to your husbands then you
are making your money off a marriage is
going to fall apart you're making money
off deception you're making money off
hurting people and there will be an end
game to your business you have to be
about how can we help you not how can we
lie to you what's the Long play
absolutely how does everyone end up more
whole healthy and prosperous when we're
done otherwise your business will go if
it's not about helping people yeah so
I'll give you an example all right uh to
go to entree leadership Master Series
I think the tickets are gone for
platinum for uh April of next year okay
there'll be about 3 000 people there
there'll be some of the top speakers in
the world and teachers in the world I'm
very very proud of what we will be doing
but to sit in a platinum seat is just
under ten thousand dollars
if you call me up and you say the way
you're gonna go
to platinum as good as Platinum is
and it might be in the Platinum
experiences and as good as Entre
leadership Master Series is might be the
best leadership conference in America
today
bar nut I mean I'm so proud of what we
do there we just completed one so you've
got high marks on your screen on your
speaking there's absolutely incredible
Dr Jordan Peterson Willie Robertson were
there with us and Malcolm Gladwell were
there with us it was an incredible
incredible event and we had guys on the
front row that paid almost ten thousand
dollars a piece to be sitting there in
that Platinum section if you call me up
and you say the way you're going to come
and sit in the Platinum section at
entree leadership as proud as I am of it
and as I know it's worth every dime is
that you're going to clean out your bank
account down to six hundred dollars and
you're going to go against your spouse's
wishes I'm going to tell you I don't
want you as a customer and you're
borrowing seven thousand yeah you need
to stay home absolutely you know I do
not want your money
you need to stay home because I don't
want your marriage just blood on I don't
I don't this is not what I do right I
don't do I mean I I sell something like
a ten thousand dollar weekend is my
point and never one time have we
knowingly accepted a situation like this
and encouraged this is the way to get
ten thousand dollars out of somebody
nope nope don't need the money that bad
boys and girls I gotta sleep later
it's not that hard a life you know this
is just wrong so honey Clark get your
marriage counselor because when your
wife says my way or the highway on
anything this is known as a flare was
just shot up off the deck of the boat
warning warning and that boat is going
down